les échos du convoi des camionneurs un
an plus tard tout près de là les élus
libéraux planifient la reprise des
travaux parlementaires Justin Trudeau
est loin d'être perturbé par la présence
des manifestants je pense que il va
certainement continuer d'avoir des gens
qui est qui russe fête pendant les mois
il peut être même les années à venir
mais le convoi des camionneurs pourrait
revenir l'embêter le rapport de la
commission rouleau sera déposé en
février le gouvernement Trudeau pourrait
être blâmé pour le recours à la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgence les élus libéraux
sont déjà prêts à tourner la page je
pense que là on passe à d'autres choses
je pense que là on est rendu ailleurs
vous savez que l'inflation le coût de la
vie le gouvernement Trudeau a du pain
sur la planche et prépare son prochain
budget il doit aussi faire débloquer les
projets de loi qui s'enlisent comme C21
sur le contrôle des armes les chasseurs
et les autochtones craignent d'être
ciblées injustement par la liste
d'interdictions proposées par les
libéraux l'opposition conservatrice ne
lâche pas
pour les enquiquiner comme il fait
depuis trop longtemps alors que les
problèmes est où le problème est dans
les villes avec les armes illégales le
Premier ministre envoie un signal
d'ouverture et pourrait retirer
certaines armes de sa liste
d'interdictions proposées on est en
train de regarder pour qualifier pour
recalibrer notre notre liste pour
s'assurer qu'effectivement les gens qui
font de la chasse vont pouvoir accéder à
des fusils qui sont parfaits pour ça
mais pas des fusils qui sont trop forts
autre dossier chaud c'est 13 et la
révision de la Loi sur les langues
officielles comment sortir du cul-de-sac
adopter pour protéger le français au
Québec cause des désaccords la Loi sur
les langues officielles est révisée à
peu près au 25 ans donc on peut pas
manquer notre coup là le français est en
déclin ou même au Québec le gouvernement
le goût souhaite que les entreprises
sous réglementation fédérale soit
soumises à la Charte de la langue
française au Québec la voix de passage
n'est pas évidente
inflation ralentissement économique le
gouvernement Trudeau doit démontrer que
malgré les crises il est capable de
garder le contrôle de son ordre du jour
en contexte minoritaire le temps est
compté et l'opposition ne lui fera pas
de cadeau ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada